Hi, Conan here.
Welcome back to our show.
We've been off the air
for a couple of weeks,
and we're back now,
taping once again
in the iconic Largo
theater in Los Angeles.
I apologize, still haven't cut
my hair, down over my eyes.
Not really quite sure
where I am right now,
but it doesn't matter.
I'm with you, and that's
the important thing.
And we have a terrific show.
Jason Sudeikis is here to talk about
his terrific new show, Ted Lasso.
So we'll be talking to
him in just a second.
Now, as I've said, we're
here at the Largo theater,
just a skeleton crew,
hardly anybody joining me here,
just to keep things COVID safe.
And let's face it, it's
pretty much an empty theater,
which can get lonely.
And I don't know, I'm not used to that.
I'm used to a crowd chanting
"We love you, you're the
best, TV icon", whatever.
This is new to me, working
in complete silence.
And then, check this out,
I was watching Major League
Baseball this past weekend,
and I got an idea.
Now, you may have seen this.
Teams have been filling their empty stands
with cardboard cutouts of fans.
Check it out. See that?
When I heard that idea, I
thought that's not gonna work,
but it actually looks pretty good.
People are okay with it.
So I asked my crew to bring
me whatever cardboard cutouts
they could find in storage at
our Warner Brothers Studio,
just random cardboard cutouts
that were hanging out
in the props department.
And guess what?
Here's what they found.
Here's what we got.
We got Ruth Bader Ginsburg, all right?
We have Conrad Bain.
Remember the dad from Different Strokes?
They found a life-size,
six-foot-six cutout
of former FBI Director, James Comey.
And for some reason, they
found four, count 'em,
four Kevin Harts.
That's my audience right now,
and I feel pretty good about it.
It actually looks like Comey is standing
to object to some comedy I just did,
but that's not the point.
The point is, I need to fill
the rest of the audience,
and here's my idea.
I wanna do it with
cutouts of my actual fans.
I'm not kidding around, this is real.
This is your chance to join my audience
in cardboard cutout form.
Okay, we're gonna make this happen.
Here's what you do.
Go to teamcoco.com/cutouts and
upload a photo of yourself.
That's right, take a photo of
yourself and then upload it.
Be sure to include your
name and city of residence.
And then, we may put you right
here in our Largo audience.
Now, in the photo, you
can, it's your choice,
you can be enjoying the show,
or if you choose, you
cannot be enjoying the show.
See, if everyone in the
audience, if I look over there,
and every single person in the audience
is enjoying the show,
that's not gonna feel realistic to me.
So once again, here's what you do, okay?
You upload a photo of yourself
and you go to teamcoco.com/cutouts,
and you'll get all the
details there on how to do it.
And who knows, you may get to sit
next to former FBI Director, James Comey,
night after night.
You may get to sit in-between
two of the four Kevin Harts.
Anything can happen.
The sky's the limit.
So let's make this happen,
and I'll give you a
shout out on television.
See, this quarantine isn't so bad.